est-ce que vous rappelez de Mathilda cet
auxiliaire de 1058 ans qui a vécu
pendant 10 ans dans un 9 m² insalubre et
inondé à Paris on l'a reçu sur notre
plateau il y a quelques jours alors
qu'elle était condamnée à payer 12000
euros à son propriétaire qu'elle affirmé
qui affirmé que cette dernière n'avait
jamais payé de loyer alors qu'elle le
payait comme ça voilà 500 euros par mois
depuis Mathilda pu changer de logement
elle revient ce soir sur notre plateau
petit récap et après on a des choses à
vous annoncer c'est parti c'est bien
la semaine dernière mathilde a été venu
sur notre plateau pour nous raconter son
calvaire depuis 10 ans la femme de 58
ans vit dans une cave insalubre de 9
mètres carrés parfois je me réveillais
avec le pied dans l'eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour toi déjà je suis très heureux de te
voir tu es magnifique tu es magnifique
vraiment je te dis magnifique alors
d'après nos informations vous devez
remettre les clés dans la dans la foulée
de ce qu'on a vu parce que tu nous avais
expliqué pour que tu pouvais aller
pouvoir avoir un nouveau logement on a
des images ici de celui-ci de ce nouveau
logement que tu vas avoir regardé les
images du logement voilà c'est le
logement que tu vas avoir
voilà donc c'est pas mal c'est bien
là-bas
foulée mais je crois qu'il y a un
problème qui t'empêchait d'emménager oui
parce que on a ils ont pas fait un peu
faire le ménage et après le travaux à
cause de la grève qui a eu avec les
sens et donc j'ai pas pu encore aller
dans ton appartient
on m'a proposé
d'aller dans un hôtel
en attendant jusqu'aujourd'hui alors la
vérité voilà c'est que voilà c'est que
là tu dois avoir les clés tu les as pas
eu aujourd'hui je te le dis
sinon tu n'as pas pu intégrer ton
logement en fait c'est pas vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a même mis les photos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ton appart salon chambre cuisine
salle de bain on a pensé à tout même les
photos tu as vu la récupérer
ma cuisine
[Rires]
c'est tout on a tout fait électroménager
les équipes sache-le on travaillait tout
le week-end les équipes d'Adèle elles
ont travaillé tout le weekend c'est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est ton salon c'est le salon
c'est le salon on a même mis
alors je tiens merci je vous dis LTM
transport et active bâtisseur grâce à
leur générosité pour nous avons pu
livrer et monter et poser le mobile on
attend encore et surtout
particulièrement les magasins buts
profondément engagés dans des actions
solidaires les magasins buts qui nous
suivent toujours sur des actions
solidaires merci à eux ils ont tout de
suite répondu présent merci à vous
on voulait te faire vraiment une
surprise alors Mathilda pour l'instant
pour l'instant tu ne peux pas tu ne peux
pas intégrer tout de suite l'appartement
parce qu'il y a des petits soucis mais
on espère que ça va se régler
je te le dis c'est que c'est que moi qui
avait les clés
[Applaudissements]
Mathilda ma chérie
j'étais tranquillement sur la route je
rentrais chez moi il y a quelqu'un qui
m'a appelé je sais pas comment il a eu
mon numéro et elle m'a parlé de Mathilda
elle m'a dit Cyril est-ce que tu peux
faire quelque chose motivé je
connaissais pas cette personne et grâce
à elle c'est grâce à Céline qui m'a
appelé qui m'ani est-ce que tu peux
aider Mathilde là c'est elle que tu dois
remercier qui était magnifique et
vraiment je vais je suis content tu vas
nous emmener tu vas nous faire des
petites vidéos tu peux nous faire des
pâtes
[Musique]
non mais tu es magnifique
vous m'avez changé
je te fais un gros bisou ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
avec nous
merci à toi merci